It’s almost impossible to release a film
that doesn’t include a single flawed stunt,
unexpected mistake, or even a minor plot hole
most fans will overlook.
When the budgets get bigger and the action
sequences and running times grow along with
them, the errors that can slip through are
often hard to believe.
And for the die-hard fans, the best bloopers
can make a film worth watching all by themselves.
Here are Screenrant’s 10 Biggest Blockbuster
Movie Mistakes You Didn’t See.
Fast Five
How do you rob the richest man in Brazil when
his money is scattered throughout Rio?
Easy.
Get him to store it all in one place.
That’s the plan for the crew of Fast Five,
aiming to steal a massive safe once the movie’s
villain has done their work for them.
It’s easier said than done, since the vault
can only be unlocked by the villain’s palm
print.
Giselle uses old fashioned sex appeal to work
around the lock, stealing his fingerprints
from her own swimsuit.
Once fans are done wondering why the villain
needed to see his money gathered if only he
could open the vault, they’ll notice it’s
his right hand that unlocks it – and they
only got the prints from his left.
The Avengers
When Earth’s Mightiest Heroes finally decide
to join forces willingly to take down Loki,
Captain America asks Black Widow if she can
pilot the team into action in a SHIELD Quinjet.
Hawkeye confirms that he can, and is invited
along for the ride.
But it doesn’t make any sense for Cap to
ask Widow in the first place.
Not only is she one of Nick Fury’s top operatives,
but Cap personally flew on a Quinjet she was
piloting earlier in the film – in two different
scenes.
Maybe his years frozen solid had an effect
on his memory.
The Return of the King
In the final chapter of Peter Jackson’s
Lord of the Rings trilogy, Aragorn realizes
that in order to defeat Sauron’s forces,
he’ll need some backup from the Army of
the Dead, doomed to haunt a nearby mountain
after betraying Aragorn’s ancestor.
They’re definitely powerful, since even
speaking their name causes a massive gust
of wind through the ranger’s tent.
More powerful than the filmmakers expected,
since a suit of armor is clearly knocked over
by the wind, falling in total silence in hopes
that viewers won’t catch it.
Good luck un-seeing that mistake.
The Dark Knight
When blockbuster action gets heated, the person
holding the camera not only has to capture
it the best way possible, but make sure they
don’t end up in the finished cut.
In The Dark Knight, an interrogation room
covered in mirrors turned out to be too much
of a challenge.
When Batman takes a hands-on approach with
Joker, the camera and its operator can all
be seen reflected for a split second beside
the two actors, an error that somehow made
it through editing.
Transformers: Age of Extinction
Fans of Michael Bay’s movies know that when
action sequences shoot for the sky, some mistakes
or confusing sequences are par for the course.
In the climactic Hong Kong battle of Age of
Extinction, star Mark Wahlberg and his daughter
flee across rooftops under heavy fire from
nearby Decepticons.
Explosions are everywhere, but one long shot
reveals it’s not quite as dangerous as it
seems.
The director loves a good explosion, and obviously
hoped fans would be distracted enough to miss
the camera man, special effects and production
team members in plain sight scattered across
the rooftop.
Jurassic Park
Steven Spielberg’s dinosaur thriller begins
with a bang, showing how deadly the park’s
Velociraptors can be.
When one is simply being moved to her new
habitat, she singlehandedly manages to kill
a park worker from inside her own cage.
When the gatekeeper tumbles from on top of
the cage, audiences were probably too terrified
to catch the hands that tried to break his
fall towards the camera.
The next shot confirms it wasn’t one of
his co-workers, but a member of the movie
crew whose hands made an unexpected cameo.
Star Trek
Few will forget the space dive sequence from
the 2009 Star Trek reboot, but those who were
paying close attention to the movie were probably
confused by the ship’s version of events.
When Kirk, Sulu and Engineer Olson are speeding
towards the planet, Kirk is – obviously
– leading the charge, with Sulu close behind
him.
When the camera immediately cuts to the bridge,
not only are they out of order, but Chekov
claims they are at a height of “20,000 metres”,
despite the screen showing a height of 102,000
metres.
The images and audio have been lifted from
later in the sequence, and spliced in ahead
of time where it’s better to ignore them.
Independence Day
Some science fiction fans may take issue with
this story of alien invaders, but there’s
one incredible error in the finished movie
that has nothing to do with computers or alien
tech.
When Jeff Goldblum’s character has given
up all hope, he turns to alcohol, and storms
his way through Area 51’s hangar bay.
His father eventually calms him down, but
not before Goldlbum kicks over a garbage can
clearly marked by the film’s “Art Department”.
The piece of set dressing drew more attention
than it ever should have.
Either that, or Area 51 is employing its own
team of artists.
Avatar
James Cameron relied on green screen and CGI
wizardry to make most of his 3D epic, so it’s
no surprise that one of the most surprising
mistakes is set right here on Earth.
Jake Sully is only given the chance to pilot
an alien Avatar because it was been grown
for his brilliant twin brother Tom, who was
killed in a robbery.
Actor Sam Worthington plays both brothers,
but when Tom’s corpse is re-covered, it
is clearly a different actor on the second
shot that was used.
We can only assume Worthington’s face was
going to be added in post-production, but
considering the other effects in the film,
it’s easy to see how this one slipped through
the cracks.
Thor: The Dark World
Jane Porter may not be powerful as the average
Asgardian, but when she absorbed the Aether
in Thor 2, she became much more than just
a brilliant human scientist.
But when the cosmic power was shown entering
her body, her wardrobe was a far cry from
the street clothes she was wearing before
and after.
She would only wear the Asgardian metal and
robes once she made the trip to Thor’s homeworld
much later.
So unless the Aether can give glimpses of
the future for no reason whatsoever, it appears
the footage was taken from later in the movie,
with the hope that fans would be too distracted
by the flowing red energy to notice the inconsistency.
We hope you liked our video!
If you're looking for a good laugh, make sure
you check out our friends at Ownage Pranks
to watch an epic prank call about one of these
movie mistakes in a video entitled "CRAZY
WalMart Movie Return Prank".
We can't believe what they were able to pull
off, but it's one of the most hilarious things
we've ever heard!
So thanks again for watching!
Did we miss any of your favorite mistakes
or errors?
Let us know in our comments section below!
If you liked the video make sure to subscribe
to our channel and check out these other videos,
especially the one from our friends at Ownage
Pranks for a guaranteed laugh!